Friday lunchtime in the centre of
Glasgow this was a chaotic harrowing
scene armed police officers rushed to
the park in inside the hotel they shot a
man dead but not before a number of
people had been stabbed witnesses heard
at least one shot fired and spoke of a
blood strewn scene when I went down
about to take the leaf the leaf inside
the leaf it was covered with blood so I
did not take the leave and I went down
to the stairs when I went down to the
stairs that's where I saw the whole
reception area was covered with blood so
what happened was I saw that one of the
reception got stabbed and he was lying
behind the desk of the reception behind
the reception his desk he was lying and
he was gasping for air witnesses spoke
of stab victims inside and outside the
building paramedics and protective suits
treated casualties on the pavement we
kind of just heard everything looked out
the window and within a few minutes went
downstairs to see what was actually
happening I could see someone lying on a
curb but I wasn't sure whether they'd
been hit with a brick or something like
that and then we saw them on the steps
they were bleeding from the torso
fortunately loss of life police sent the
six people injured included a 42 year
old mill police officer taken to
hospital with stab wounds and in a
critical condition as armed officers
left the scene police Scotland ruled out
terrorism as a factor and issued a
statement on events inside the park in
and those involved officers were on the
scene within two minutes and armed
officers shortly afterwards and the
incident was quickly contained
a man was shot by armed police and have
subsequently died six other men in
hospital for treatment
including a 42 year old police officer
who is in a critical but stable
condition
the Park Inn is one of a number of
hotels in this city used to house asylum
seekers and refugees since the start of
the corona virus pandemic campaigners on
their behalf
have one complained that they have been
living in intolerable conditions which
were having a significant impact on
their mental health this has been a
dreadful afternoon for the city of
Glasgow and particularly for those who
have been directly involved those
injured obviously but there will have
been people who witnessed it this
afternoon particularly in the location
of this incident at quite horrific
events and I think I will not be alone
across Scotland tonight and thinking of
everybody who has in any way been
affected by what unfolded investigations
into what happened here will continue
long after the scene here has cleared
those inquiries are for the longer term
the more immediate concern is coming to
terms with the carnage that unfolded on
this city centre Street